the loneliness and the isolation that we
all felt during covet is part of what
gave cuenon such power you know because
we were turning to these sort of
radicalized groups online to fulfill to
fill those voids yeah
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god
with me george lopez
sport sport sporting paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
the president of a t or brinks
brings alarm company like that and he
says you know what i'm going to give you
the best alarm that we have
and nice thank you very nice of you
and it was a sign
all it said was sorry i won't touch it
this
house
is patrolled and controlled by brick
security
i'm sorry by brink's security
and
he says his best thing best deterrent
you can ever have
in interviewing richard richard says
the only thing that kept them away from
going inside a house is that they had a
good security assistance
so how do you know it's a good security
system
they got signs
oh just a sign would do just the sign is
a deterrent
he says people pay monthly fees for all
this [ __ ] he says the sign in mind
hunter you know they were gonna if they
did season three
there was going to be the bts guy in
kansas city in wichita
and they were setting it up with little
vignettes of thing and uh he was he
worked for adt i think i looked like he
worked for adt and then
the lady was kind of like you know she
looked a little bit nervous and she said
my husband wanted me to ask you like you
guys don't sell the signs do you uh-huh
joseph signs he goes no ma'am
that's that would be illegal
yeah and she's like oh okay
uh because you know if you had a sign
yeah
the sign is like eighty percent of it
yes it is yeah because because if you
have an alarm
and you have to set it every time you go
out it is i mean listen it's worse to be
robbed but you come in your hands are
full you forget and you hear that
and then it's you have 20 seconds to
turn it off oh my god i remember i
babysat for these rich people when i
first moved here and they had just the
most
obnoxious alarm system and i was like i
pretty much am an intruder like i've
eaten all their snacks
yeah this should go off because of me
yeah
i've never armed mine
i've never armed the house would you
have more than one weapon in your house
yeah
one i haven't
came from the day where a frying pan was
like you know they were chasing down the
street
no i have the most insane story like
when i was a kid we i was in sixth grade
and we had just moved into a new house
with an alarm system and
um my sister was home alone while my mom
dropped me off at a friend's house and
she set the alarm and my dad came home
and turned off the alarm and like as a
joke was like crawling up the stairs to
like scare her
and she literally jumped out of the
window
wasn't wearing pants
jumped out of the window went to the
neighbor's house they called the cops
and then when my mom and i came back to
the house like there was like
six cop cars out in front of the house
and my dad was like in cuffs
and i'm colombian my dad has an accent
he was like he was like no like i'm he's
i'm her dad i'm her dad and my sister
wasn't wearing her contacts
[Applause]
but it ended up being fine but it was
like honestly like insane
whoa her fighter flight is yeah you know
she is uh was it the she went out the
window like that's she went out the
window that's some intestinal fortitude
right there yeah seriously she went this
you could go out the back door you could
hide in a closet
[ __ ] it she went outside straight out
the window yeah yeah i wouldn't have
done it
[ __ ] i would have been like take me yeah
whatever
you know what your mind thinks you what
what your mind remembers you doing and
what you can do physically
there's a disconnect of i'm sure you
guys have like try to jump over like you
know when you're young i i was with my
daughter we used to go to the grand
wailea and they have like a rope that's
tied in knots and all the kids and even
some adults were getting on it and they
would hold the knot and slide out and
they would do backflips and i had it in
my head that i was going to swing out
and then let go and the minute i
held it it just went through i put it
it's like
i almost hit my back of my leg on the
edge of the of the pool and they were
like are you all right sir and i was
like yeah i'm good i just kind of lost
my grip but in my head i had a different
vision for myself yeah
i remember my neighborhood there's a guy
not a real name but we just call him
eskimo and he was just a little funny
you know he was a little tough kid and
he's up on the roof and he hit his head
he had a towel big beach towel tied
around his neck he says what's up i'm
superman and he jumped off the roof
he broke his arm and his dad came with a
ben that would start beating the [ __ ]
out of
like when you're a kid you're sort of i
think experimenting with like what's
real can i like imagine something i want
to be true into existence and so he was
probably thinking like if i say i'm
superman and jump off the roof with a
towel wrapped around my neck maybe i
will fly
should have changed his name to
superbottle
[Laughter]
even if you land okay and do one roll
yeah but not where
how old was he
ah
late 13 14 years old okay that's a
little old we put it right now around
one of my friend's brothers and we're
pulling them up
because i want to come up there they put
like a rope around them and oh my god we
were pulling him up and he got to about
this where we reached out and the rope
snapped
vertically he went like this all the way
back
oh my god not only did his mom like make
us go home the whole was the whole
street was empty like i don't know
yeah nobody wall street was vacant back
then i i guess my street
other parents would beat the [ __ ] out of
the he screwed up you did something
wrong they they yeah i like those things
they would say can you hit that guy can
you hit that kid right there you go this
one's bam no there's like the classic of
like you mess up and then you're scared
that your parents are gonna like beat
you up for messing up or for like
breaking an arm or something you know
they're to be like hey what did you do
or the other one well there's an
emergency at school when they get there
they look at you like i'm going to
[ __ ] kill you they look at you oh
that would be my mom sorry you had to
leave work today sir yeah
but then are those there are those
parents who like immediately assume it
was the other person's fault and you can
tell which kids grew up in which home no
no not in my home yeah not in my home it
was always my fault school was always
right yeah i think my parents often
forgot they had kids
[Laughter]
amanda's parents are scientists they're
very important people
are they're scientists they are
yeah my mom is a cancer cell biologist
and my dad's a neuroscientist well i
can't even spell those words
they are tricky wow
and what is their work in
a cure for cancer my mom yeah she
studies how cells move which is
important for
my mom literally had cancer when i was
11 and like helped design her own
treatment plan amazing yeah so it was
easy to forget that you had kids
i think you would yeah if you're trying
to cure cancer and you're like i'm
hungry stay
yeah it's like i think i could just put
cells away every time you get hungry
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's fascinating
because um
it's i think it you know there's so much
disconnection in people in the world but
i think the one thing that connects
people more than people want to admit it
is
you know illness cancer it's so true
yeah see somebody
go through it and to see what that looks
like yeah we should do like a like some
like there some episode on it because
there i feel like there's like some
horrible conspiracy theories on like how
people like haven't found the cure
like intentionally oh i said oh right
because the cancer society yeah exactly
yeah exactly there are some like deep
deep deep conspiracy theories i mean in
part like some of these things are
rooted in like semi truths because like
it is in like
a doctor is incentivized to sell you
drugs not always to make you better but
people obviously spend a lot of control
um
i'm gonna say yeah you know there were
there were these alleged hospitals that
are like cancer care hospitals which are
a little like almost boutique but then
your doctor would send you over there
and when you get there
they just tell you you're better or
you're getting better but you're really
not as sick as they made you believe you
were sick oh my god this is like that
podcast dr death and they make you think
that you i got i when i went there i got
better when i got there i was in one
because oh they tell you you were sicker
and then you get there and in a month
they look at your number and you go
you're you're you're a lot better than
you numbers are improved
and you're like where are you getting
these numbers yeah right from right here
yeah
your mother's
studying cells cancer cells and how they
with
big pharmaceuticals
they don't want to hear this stuff about
you
solving the question because they want
to push their drugs yeah well they want
to buy out doctors and scientists and
stuff like this
in order
well luckily so my my parents work in
what's called basic science which i
think is kind of derogatory it's not
that basic but basically but yeah which
means that like there's no end game
they're not trying to profit off of the
science they like work for a university
but we've had a lot of requests to do an
episode on the cult of academia though
we should yeah
um
okay let's let's let's put a let's let's
put the introduction here because yeah
they're fascinating there's a lot of
there's a lot of great things to talk
about so can you introduce our guests
because i i always cuss
joining us on the podcast today we have
is medina and amanda montel uh hosts and
creators of the sounds like a cult
podcast which is all about the modern
day colts okay follow uh how do people
find
i always do the last first how do people
find your podcast because you were
listening to it and i love it i was
listening to it yes and walking around
the house listening to it which i'd
i'd be like [ __ ] that i'll get i'll
catch you when i get back up but but i
was walking with my and i was in the
house so with i think it's great how do
people find it where can they find it
how do they download it
and how can they get it fast
yeah it's available wherever you stream
your podcast apple spotify spotify
we were on amazon we were on their audio
platform and now we're on their amazon
platform uh okay all right so on
amazon surprise
instagram if you follow us on sounds
like a cult pod
supplementary content
i think it's fantastic if if somebody
like i know a lot of latinos don't like
to listen to people talk yeah
so that's fair but but it is
but a lot of people run in the mornings
they walk
and they you know do their thing and
they that's how i think podcast has kind
of gained the the popularity yeah and
i think as a culture we need it more
because it's like
information that's easy to understand
and the way that you guys have a way of
doing it both very smart and it's and
funny as well and you get a lot of
information in a short amount of time
yeah instead of motto yeah
if you go on a nice 30-minute walk we
don't want to accompany you on your we
love big ass hike we love to call them
snackable episodes snackable which i
think latinos would appreciate you know
but you can do it at any time you need
to do it on a drive it's perfect for
like a 30 minute drive or a 30 minute
walk in your laundry listen to one of my
drive in yeah there you go we're just
trying to start our own cult so we want
to like be in your ear as much as
possible wherever you go and how did you
two meet how did how did you guys become
friends and how did this
become a business
we met at a party girl boss yeah partner
we had a pregame actually i think we met
the old school way yeah before covid we
were at a party we were at a party she
was like i don't know we were both
cracking jokes and then we started
cracking jokes together and then we got
along pretty well you hadn't heard of
each other before no
we met yeah through a mutual friend and
then after that we started hanging out
like
just us too you brought me to kind of a
bad movie
wait which one ah i don't want to say it
no no i'll say it you know it the
assistant have you guys heard oh sure
love the people in it matthew mcfadden
julian
yeah garner gardner yeah
but it's so depressing and i felt so bad
because i thought it was gonna be like
it's about a hollywood assistant and
it's about you know like all the things
that they have to go through but it was
specifically about it was a little
harvey weinstein
yeah so it was a little darker than i
expected like i thought it was going to
be like upbeat and be like oh this is
what happened hi jinx hi jinx but no it
was devastating and we were all just
sitting there like oh super slow burn
and it was like the third time we'd hung
out you two remind me right now
of the characters on saturday night live
that did the thing sweaty balls
i don't know the reference but i'm
honored that was guilt george lopez was
very quiet during their they were their
they're cookies
and who's the guy that just got the
shooting it's it's it's alec baldwin
like his mpr two radio hosts
who's the guy that did the shooting on
the set
not the guy that for 30 rock forget 30.
gary glenn ross
well you're oh you remember you're
remembered for your latest work and that
is his latest work
thank you thank you
and what a great name for a movie i
thought as well but there's a lot of
things going on there yeah
in in that
we have an episode on the cult of
hollywood forthcoming so yeah i want to
talk about a little bit about
let's talk about
if you know people come here alone you
know they move from different parts of
the world to being that to be
entertainers you know and they come here
and they don't really know anybody and
they don't really have much money
you know that's one thing that's i think
and people live in their car right they
live in their car and they go to try to
go to clubs or they go try to be guitar
people or they go to the beach and do
all that stuff but it's
not it's very dangerous for sure because
when you combine lack of resources with
big dreams all of a sudden that person
becomes very easy to exploit yeah and
lack of community is something that we
always talk about
it's just like these people come to this
place where they don't know anyone like
you said and and then they all they're
seeking is friendship and community and
like that's where you're really
vulnerable i mean that's what i talk
about scientology in my book and we
touch on it on in on the podcast i was
i'm con confused by the preposition on
the podcast in the podcast whatever on
yeah um so anyway uh that's a huge way
that scientologists can recruit people
as they promise them like oh this is an
artist workshop for aspiring actors or
comedians and they lead with the the
ideology and the pitch that's easiest to
get on board with have you uh done
podcasts about scientology
not yet we've touched on it here and
there do you know
do you know that um have you been
involved or do you have been around
anybody that's a scientist
already that even sounds derogatory yeah
you're like excited yeah are you reading
the door it's like the harry potter it's
like voldemort like you can't say it
yeah they even
i don't want to mention anything
i know
somebody who's married to somebody that
was in there
yes they're going to come out of the
program oh at any time like a siren
sounds while i'm doing like an instagram
live or something i'm always like the
scientologists are coming to sue me
that's a song
it could be that's why amanda has
spotted much like anxiety honestly i
feel like how about you do have a lot of
anxiety huh
thank you
if you're creative you could turn into
creative actually speaking of the
scientologist so after my book came out
first of all scientologists aren't
supposed to read my book because it
would be considered black pr they're not
supposed to read anything that's
critical of their religion do they call
it black pr they call it black pr that's
their label for it um but someone i
guess broke the rules and and read my
book and then wrote a blog post about it
that showed up in my like whatever my
google alerts for my own name and um i
thought it was amazing because uh the
the title of the blog post was amanda
montel needs to calm down like about
scientology they're like it's really not
that bad and she's critiquing it too
harshly but the funny part about that uh
blog title is that i really do need to
calm down it's like so taylor swift
a song
yeah you need to come down so the
scientologists want to like sponsor a
meditation retreat for me or whatever
like i'm okay you should have them send
you to hawaii or something yeah
i need to comment make sure you get the
return ticket too yeah
do you um you would be into that
um i love free [ __ ] uh
if it's coming from the scientologist
i wouldn't immediately shut it down but
you know um yeah they have a way of of
communicating that
i mean it's
man i don't want to say you know when
you go i bought a car one time
with no money like i didn't know what
the [ __ ] i was doing all of a sudden i
drive up in a car the guy's like wavy
i'm like what the [ __ ] did i talk about
your grandmother about giving me money
for the car
oh and i just got into a thing where the
guy was
he was using his salesman tricks on me
and i was not i didn't go there to buy a
car i went to look at a car and then i'd
drive off the line my grandma was like
what the [ __ ] did you do you bought this
[ __ ]
you know like i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened like the next thing i know i'm
signing i mean well leaders really are
just like fantastic marketers and sales
people have a way of
it's it's um
verbal it's what a detective would do
it's it's verbal
it's verbal it's it's a it's it's judo
it's like
they come to you and they say something
that puts them
on a higher plane than you or maybe say
something to you and you feel like oh
how did they know that i feel like
something they also do is just like
less is more with them is like they
listen a lot they let you speak so then
they know everything about you and then
they can use what they know about you to
manipulate you and that's why i can
never manipulate anyone because all i do
is talk
but i need to listen it's so true i mean
they do
make you feel like they're speaking
uniquely to you even though the words
themselves that they're using are pretty
generic they're just so emotionally
charged that you're like whoa like you
understand me in a way that no one else
has ever been able to and is there a
certain type of person that goes into
like i would never have been in law
enforcement so there is a
cult of
of attracting similar types yeah you
know of not knowing somebody and then
all of a sudden feeling like you've
known them forever right but there is in
some manipulation in
in time of saying instead of a year
i got to get i got to make this happen
like
a lot faster than that totally the
easiest thing to do is
lie to somebody because all you have to
do is tell them something they want to
hear yeah yeah yeah that's that's a way
of manipulation you tell them something
they would like to hear
you know i've read your book and that's
the best book i've ever written you have
to what at least at least 10 years in
the making
thank you you see now i've never read
your book
but oh my gosh that was great we do hear
what we want to hear obviously but also
we don't immediately assume that people
are lying like there is some bias in us
that is a great book though is that yeah
i'm going to read it
it's called cultish no but i mean it's
it's fascinating sure um it's
fascinating yeah you did that really
well too yeah i was like damn
that was a quick greeting
it's manipulation it's true i mean and
there are plenty of messages that would
not resonate with me but that one
certainly
yeah but i think i mean we can talk
about this because well issa keeps
finding herself in the type of cults
that we talk about on our show like the
soul cycle and the taylor swift stands
and the such but the type of person
who's most likely to wind up like 10
years into scientology or in another
cult is not necessarily who you might
think like you think of this person as
like desperate disturbed intellectually
deficient but i found in my reporting
that the common thread is really this
like over abundance of idealism this
like faith that solutions to the world's
most urgent problems are able to be
found and if you align with this person
or this group whatever it may be whether
it's the cult of people telling you you
have a great book or whatever like you
have the ability to be a part of that
change yeah optimism
why did you chuckle at soul cycle or
which one did you check
oh i'm in that cult i'm not gonna lie
but it's all of your life so we're gonna
live your life
we always say on the podcast like i
always like end up slipping and falling
into like all these little cults but i
never stay too long because i have um
what is it commitment issues yeah
even commitment to something that that
is uh um
stationary yeah yeah even commitment to
getting my flight home
that's true and that's why she's here
everybody
yeah i cancelled my flight because i
like was tired and then but then i
needed to book a new flight i booked it
like this morning for tomorrow oh no
because i was like i don't know i
haven't reached i haven't booked my
return where do you live
oh well i live in la but my parents live
in northern virginia oh so you're gonna
go oh wow yeah so going back to northern
northern virginia
and is was that a trait that was around
do your parents have that honestly
actually yes now that i think about it
my parents never planned a vacation more
than like a month and a half yeah
because you know i thought of this today
i wanted to tell you guys that back when
people are born they're not born with
like loving like we're talking about one
about football they're not they're not
born with loving music or they're not
born with by with reading
or traveling
it's something that i guess would be in
the people that
raise you and and you're surrounded by
that
um it's conditioning and nurturing
conditioned yeah
i never did my dad i don't ever remember
my dad taking a vacation until after he
retired he had cancer
three years when he retired he lived
three more years and that's when he took
a vacation
i'm not one to
hey let's go on vacation you know when
my wife want to go to europe let's go to
europe she really wanted to that's the
only reason i went because she really
wanted i didn't want to go and i don't
care about traveling around around the
world or anything like that well i you
know i we didn't travel my grandparents
didn't travel they went with a guy from
a radio station like this guy alberto
luna out here and he would do trips with
with a travel agency and they'd go to
like mazatlan as a radio station trip
like you call this number you can go but
we never went
on a trip and um
when i met my wife in the early 90s when
i was married then we started to go to
like rome and i saw the coliseum you
start to see things that you like the
vatican you start to see things that
my grandparents talked about going to
rome and and you go there and you think
you know it's they made it seem and pop
like impossible to go so what are we
supposed to do just leave
yeah
but [ __ ] you have time like they were
younger than right and they didn't go
and you know procrastination is the cult
of seriously yeah procrastinating where
at the end of the road we only have so
much time you you look back and you
don't think of what they say you don't
think of the things you did you think
the things that you didn't do yeah well
also in this culture like we don't
prioritize or value leisure the way that
we prioritize and value like work and
not taking off and not making your boss
angry um which i think is you know works
a disservice to us but but i think we
traveled a lot when i was growing up but
it was like the one time when i saw my
parents my poor parents they were good
i just picture her doing homework
but you're not you're not gonna try to
cure cancer and go i'll be back at 2 30.
you know you know
you're going to be gone a while yes and
my children will be abandoned and the
nice thing is they do now
i feel like in a way they kind of made
it up because they ended up moving to
the state where you now live yeah that's
true so now they're like driving now
we're all besties as adults yeah but i
think you know it is true like the
conditioning that you go through uh
growing up will lend itself to whether
or not you might find yourself in a cult
um like there are certain belief systems
that i'm way more skeptical skeptical of
than others and that's why like i came
to the the topic of cults with my own
preconceived notions of like oh cults
are these like woo-woo destructive like
spiritual groups of people who are
deranged or naive um without realizing
that like no one is immune to the charms
of a charismatic guru yeah yeah and that
was really hard and honestly like even
though we've done a lot of episodes of
like get the [ __ ] out level cults it's
still something that's really hard for
me to like digest of like oh my god
those people were just being stupid
right well we do that to protect
ourselves because we want to tell
ourselves oh this would have never been
a threat to me
all they're doing is getting to believe
in faith and faith is just something
that
logically isn't so
you know you're blind followers so
that's what they do they pray upon you
and if you're that type that is looking
for leadership that's why you have so
many sheep and very few
leaders yeah we're also conditioned to
want to put our faith into certain types
of people like jim joe i mean we make
this joke all the time that like elrond
hubbard greg glassman the guy who
founded crossfit elon musk like all
these dudes could be first cousins
they're like the type of people that we
you know have been conditioned to trust
with
our uh you know with god government
money
yeah historically but also it never did
much for me
well
but but cult almost has it's is it
derogatory to most people
the word cult is it i think it has these
negative connotations i think it's more
negative than positive right definitely
but
name a positive cult out there
well so those are like the live your
life levels yeah we talk about but the
word the word cults and its sinister
connotations have a lot to do with um
our culture's relationship to community
and spirituality and identity and
meaning cult actually didn't always have
this inherently nefarious undertone it
wasn't really until the media coverage
of the manson murders
and the jonestown massacre that cults
were put on the average american radar
as something we should all know
something we should all fear but there
are tons of jokes that religious
scholars will make like cult plus or
like cult plus time equals religion like
the word cult is so inherently
subjective having so much to do with
like cultural normativity it's like but
in religion like you know there's
baptist the southern baptist methodist
but it
is it kind of all
the same as in a sense but the different
book slightly different book i mean i
think the word cult is not enough to be
able to determine yeah yeah i think like
or i feel like organized religion is all
from fall under that umbrella i don't
think yeah that's why we haven't done
scientology on the episode because yet
because once we do scientology we have
to do like mormonism and we have to
touch on all the other ones
and you don't know followed yeah but but
if someone's living their life you know
like no premarital sex they don't drink
they have
alcohol
and
you know uh but but in a sense we would
think that you know they're they're
you're missing out yeah but they but
because those kind of standards were
created there's not they think some
people yeah some people have suggested
like the call instead of like the cult
of veganism
like the cult of alcohol because it kind
of is a cult like you know when you're
not drinking you go to dinner with
friends and everyone gets a drink and
you don't people are going to be like oh
come on
people are going to be like why aren't
you getting a drink
yeah you don't have another one by the
way we've got beer if you guys want
something oh yeah i love alcohol um i do
but uh but right so we're we're kind of
addressing in like this humorous and
light-hearted way on our podcast that
like cultishness is something that
imbues so many spaces not just like
compounds where everybody wears a robe
and has a shaved head that's a different
you know level of stakes and
consequences than you know soul cycle or
fraternities and sororities i don't know
why i'm pointing to you
what if you're wearing a robe and you're
shaving your head like those people are
scientology
all right
since we're uh here among comedians uh i
met um this is not meant to be name
droppy but i um i met dimitri martin
like a few weeks ago and he taught me a
fun trick where um if you want to like
tell a story about something
unflattering like diarrhea or something
you can like uh do a drive-by where you
like motion to someone to reference that
like they had something oh yeah like you
know so-and-so had diarrhea what
happened to me
that happened to me at a comedy show
there was like a comedian on stage and
he was talking about like racism and he
was a black comedian and he was like
speaking of racism time to introduce
your next comedian yeah isa medina and i
was like what
i was like i was like i posted the black
square i deleted the black square i was
like
oh i just like leaned into it i was like
a joke but i was like that was so
interesting
i mean everybody kind of gathers i think
it at some point you kind of draw people
that
um have similar likes you know i don't
know why how you decided to be a
comedian but yeah it's it's not it's a
cult it's like
and it was the community aspect of it
for me because like you know you start
going to open mics you meet people then
those people become your friends and
then i feel like you're addicted to it i
am addicted to stand-up comedy
i mean i don't know how do you feel
about stand up
yeah gail
there's absolutely nothing wrong with it
i love stand-up comments yeah there's
nothing wrong with it but it's addiction
it's not hurting anyone well
that's a different conversation yeah
you know it's and this is just oh
this isn't just this isn't kissing his
ass
but before i ever met george i had paid
to go see him at least five times
yeah i i love this comedy i love
comedy i just but mine was created out
of isolation really
yeah no yeah i moved to l.a i knew
nobody
yeah i still spend a lot of time alone
like i
you know i golf and do all this stuff
but you know i even you know my
therapist he goes even the things you've
chosen to do you could do alone
play the guitar
play golf you know um
watch you i mean i
i don't really have a lot of interaction
with with people i mean and i'm fine
with that like it's not you know it's
not
it's not
it's kind of the way i i came up like
i'm not different now than i was you
know my my therapist like tried to try
to get you like what were you doing when
you were 12. i'm like the same [ __ ] i'm
doing now trying to learn the guitar in
a little room watching tv are you still
playing with yourself george no
i don't know literally same i like have
this debate with people all the time
about like whether or not people change
and i'm like yo when i was 12 i was
literally just like talking at people
wearing pink
yeah i think i think
you just kind of like
get more of a little more glow you know
because in the beginning you're younger
and then you learn more ways and you're
just like a little more broader but
yeah it's still the same as a kid i
would always get my ass kicked because i
wouldn't stop laughing i couldn't stop
playing
come to my shows
i still do and i remember uh in boot
camp i was only 17 years old for
christ's sake and we're standing there
and this d.i comes up he's i'll be your
girlfriend i'll be this i'll be that and
if you mess with me i'll burn your ass
i'm just like a flame i'll burn your ass
every time
and it sounded funny
like that
and he comes up and he gets my face
what's so funny maggot and he's no
he says you thought it was funny huh i
said sir yes sir and he said okay i
think if this is funny and he got behind
me and he kicked me right in my ass oh
[ __ ] i went he launched me i went bam i
went forward
and i laughed when i hit the ground
because that had to look funny yeah i
just i really do think well i saw like
some [ __ ] quote graham on instagram
the other day that actually resonated
with me it was like the only two people
you need to impress in life are your
five-year-old self and your 85 year old
self if we're so lucky to live that long
it's like you want to try to be
authentic to the person that you were
that was the most unmitigated like not
ruined by the world and all the
expectations and then you want to
impress like the self that's looking
back on my life being like what what did
i miss out on what did i not miss out on
like you want to serve that person
what's also bad that's not very true but
what's also bad is like your your whole
mind is formed between like 0 and 10
and the traumatic [ __ ] that's gonna
happen to you you almost wish a bubble
would pop up like they said you don't
have a father okay
and you pop up like don't worry about it
man it's not that big
instead of thinking this is gonna [ __ ]
with me for the rest of my life
yeah it's like it's not a big deal man a
lot of kids don't have fathers but it
doesn't and in that time you either
become
a welcoming person or you become a
guarded person or you become somebody
that you can never make sad or somebody
that's always sad in the in the first 10
years of your life i haven't i haven't
changed at all you know i thought to
breakfast the other day with my wife and
her brothers they get together once a
month when somebody drops uh plates do
you clap
i clap oh my gosh my sister cop's like
so passive aggressively she's like
like the slow clap
but when growing up that's something
that like affected me is like if you
spilled a glass of water if you dropped
a plate my dad would yell and so like i
remember like the first time i like
broke a plate in my in my apartment as
an adult i was like oh [ __ ]
and then i looked around i was like oh
[ __ ]
nothing's gonna happen in europe i was
in amsterdam and then somebody somebody
dropped stuff and and silence
nobody said anything they said they just
went on with their breakfast nobody said
like [ __ ] a nice move yeah
out of because here we have to we almost
feel like we have to shame somebody over
yeah yeah we're so [ __ ] smug over
here like relax yeah
what the [ __ ] and it's everybody yeah
yeah a [ __ ] homeless dude i tried to
give him some shoes he was like [ __ ] i
don't like those [ __ ] [ __ ]
you don't have shoes i try to bring you
[ __ ] you don't have shoes he's like i
didn't wear those [ __ ] shoes
what are you [ __ ] okay
with ugly no literally i think this
profound mistrust of other people who
are trying to help or whatever is part
of what makes americans so prone to
cultishness i think we like mistrust
these institutions like this rich guy
trying to give me shoes or whatever it
is to the point where we're like i'm
gonna look to this alternative group
like they probably have the answers more
than the government the health care
system i feel like it's it's weird
though because i feel like even though
the individualism
makes us like not trust institutions
americans very much are like so quick to
become best friends with an individual
yeah you know like in american culture
you like immediately become you're like
you meet a girl or you meet a guy and
you're like oh my god you're like my
best friend and people say i love you so
fast i always think of that you know
like always so much
and like in in latin america or in
europe like you don't you don't do that
you don't do that you do that with like
your direct family oh my god one of my
sons
and one of my daughters the very same
thing yeah you dropped the word love oh
i love that person oh i love them i love
it
i said it almost takes away the meaning
you know from the words true well in
spanish is there the difference between
like platonic love and romantic love
because in italian there's like tivoli
which means like i love you like a
friend or i love you in a warm close way
but not in a romantic way and then
there's tiamo and when you like
transition from one to the next it's
like this step yeah it's like we don't
have
mucho is like i like you a lot but de
amo is like
it's like i'm in love with you yeah
we have a link i always just
yeah because it's like kisses but you
don't like saying like but then they
teach that to kids too like you know uh
babies
they do the lips but yeah it's like
but yeah but i feel like because people
like trust those individuals
then
you shouldn't have trust an individual
because there's nothing to
support that person there's nothing to
endorse that person right it's almost
ironic it's like an institution has like
more of a universal endorsement yeah
individual is like more dangerous to
trust in because they can only be
watching out for themselves it's so true
it's like we are more willing to trust
the like the rebel like the one who's
lying to your face versus the one who's
like lying in a strategic way what is
that
yeah american exceptionalism
what about
before when you when you drove down the
street there was no one spinning a sign
trying to get you to go into this place
right and now
[Music]
around tax time or restaurants or they
dress somebody up like a [ __ ] statue
of liberty and they're spinning a sign
to go and do your taxes but that's
for a person of a certain
kind of vibe right i kind of yeah
yeah i've never been lured somewhere by
a scientist yeah
respect because they can do a lot of fun
tricks but it's not going to convince me
that that like tax place is better
yeah yeah yeah because i think it i mean
there's a certain
amount of money i think you that you
would be like oh man finally somebody
that i can talk to you know they're
spinning a sign where most people would
just just kind of go through that so
every
day
there's levels of
of
manipulation manipulation when i went to
carl's jr one time and
um
[Music]
there was this family there and they
were all had to be like
300 pounds
and they were sitting there eating and
when they were that's when they put the
number on your
plate and they all had a number so like
oh [ __ ] they got four numbers there's
four of them they're usually just one
number
oh my god they brought this food and
they didn't talk to each other just went
in and i was like i was literally just
yesterday you know that like netflix
explained docu series or whatever i was
just watching or no i was watching a vox
video sorry related about um
[ __ ] i don't know youtube no the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] i watch all in a row when i get
high at night like the algorithm just
like takes me and i surrender whatever i
was watching this video about like how
the manipulative techniques that fast
food restaurants um employ to get people
to spend more money and thus like gain
more weight and and they're you know
they're preying on the vulnerabilities
of a certain like socio-economic class
it's just like it's true like marketing
and cult manipulation that venn diagram
is like
you know what i got out of carl jr
they had the numbers they had heavy-duty
plastic tents you know they put on your
table
i started using those i found out where
they manufactured them at when bought a
bunch to use them in homicide crime
scenes
oh
put them out get the [ __ ] out i really
did because the cheap [ __ ] that we had
when they took the body away you went
and got them yeah yeah
i'm paying how about reduce reuse
recycles
like bullet one yeah
that we use them as evidence because the
other ones were so cheap they blow away
wind come up they'd start these were
good actually resourceful
when did police tape show up and he said
like in the 70s right yeah
police tape
and then it just showed up everything we
have is so [ __ ] new i think about
people who lived like even just a
thousand years ago yeah yeah a quick
thousand i was gonna say with gps
that always messes me up oh yeah when i
was a kid and we would go on road trips
um what was it like the map thing you
have to print it out map questions map
quest is the one thomas guys
yeah yeah
but you had to like know where you were
going print it out and if like the
printer was broken you had to like write
it down yeah i [ __ ] loved mapquest
though and i still kind of wish we had
that because google maps was janky this
morning and it's janky every time yeah
yeah what is it
google i know but is it on purpose do
they do that [ __ ] on purpose i can't no
i think they just suck
but how about that they're listening to
your conversation like if you're no i
genuinely think they say we're talking
about barbecue like oh i need to get a
barbecue and then your phone
oh they're listening i sat in on a
meeting once uh like i interned at the
un and we were doing this like
i know
flex casual uh did you know that
mention we were doing a campaign while i
was interning there and like they wanted
they wanted to like mark it on instagram
so that the you this is why i stopped
working at the un because they like
hired an ad agency to help with the
marketing and i was like you guys are
like spending money on like marketing
instead of like [ __ ] the stuff you're
supposed to be helping with yeah so i
was like whatever this is stupid but we
had a meeting with an ad agency and in
that meeting they literally said do you
guys want to like implement the thing
where like the
iphone is listening to the person and
then like if they talk about like human
rights
issues then like your ads will like pop
up and i was like oh so this is real
yeah
no the surveillance is real i mean
remember all that edward snowden [ __ ]
there's always a whistleblower and yet
like all of this is so much for us this
handle
this is why web 3
decentralized internet crypto is
important talk to us a little bit oh my
god can we talk about i don't know what
weapon whoa
you know what i explained no i don't
know either i'm just like oh uh we well
we need a whole other episode on this
but web 3 is the sec is another word for
like uh like the decentralized internet
which is like
uh like cryptocurrency and blockchain
like instead blockchain itself like can
build its own internet so that later
people can like like you know how like
when you go on the internet now
you go on it through google like you
open your browser immediately it's like
google or yahoo or something else it's
the four big companies that control the
internet right now it's like google
facebook
yahoo hotmail i don't know and
um i don't know which one's controlled
yeah remember jeeves and like in the
future
they don't jesus was a homie but i'll
wrap it up really quickly by saying like
web 3 is like they're trying to make it
accessible to everyone so that in the
future like you can just access it
they're not following
yes it's just open it's just the desert
the people in the crypto space yeah but
those people scare me they're like
insult weirdos aren't they uh not all of
them many i think that you went on i
think the q and i were watching that
watching a little bit of the thing i
think it's russia like it's the bots
there's not a cute there's not a cube oh
you think
russia well there are theories about who
it is
become this spider web that touches
every breed of conspiratorial thinking
that exists now so you could almost be
in q anon and not even know it because
some influencer who knows a cue and
honor
gets all up in your algorithms exactly
dude
like pizzagate they went in there the
guy had a [ __ ] rifle he's like you
know they got pedophiles downstairs and
they're in the closet the guy's like
that's not a closet man it's like
[ __ ] storage it's like there's like
pizza sauce and the cheese in there yeah
the guy came in there and was holding a
[ __ ] assault weapon just because and
he was driving and on facebook he's
facebooking and saying hey i'm going on
my way over i'm going to save these kids
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like what
even is an influencer anymore it used to
be someone who would sell you a shitty
eye cream and now it's someone selling
you like violence and your own soul yeah
yeah totally and you know
uh shoe companies
um
there was a woman that's been around
hollywood like for comedians and people
like forever 30 plus years
and they removed her and that company
only deals with influencers and not
like just regular people like they don't
there's some stores that that are only
influencers only sure if you went in
there they wouldn't sell you anything
that's a cult itself that's another
that's another thing like they get more
out of it forget about like an
advertising campaign if someone on
instagram that has millions of followers
gets these shoes and they put them on
there to them that's mission
accomplished rather than you know
prepping an ad what do you think of this
i would move this around
they just do that
oh my god when i was like doing
interviews for my book i had someone um
put on the table that like the next
crusades will not be religious but
consumerist like hypebeasts [ __ ]
beating each other up over whatever
their allegiance to a certain brand like
this is what's fulfilling our desires
for community and ritual and purpose
it's like brands and influencers rather
than clergy which i don't even know i
don't even know what's better i feel
like that's already the case even when
like you like an artist that someone
else likes the artist that doesn't like
that artist like when two artists have
beef then like you have beef with the
fan of that artist we're just such
tribalists you know completely
just looking for meaning
that being said anyone have bad bunny
tickets
that they can say
is he out here he's coming in
february to
i think the now crypto stadium
we only have a podcast so isa can like
advertise her desire to go to the bad
bunny oh my god that would be amazing
i love bad body all of this is so worth
it
and when did you first see bad bunny
i've never seen him live but when did
you first see the like like let's go
back to
you know kiss so i'm a chicano in san
bernardino valley over here and i don't
know how i [ __ ] got into kiss but i
was kissed they you know that's what
they say like kiss freak yeah they're
the kiss freak but i love kiss they're
not led zeppelin bob yeah i was a little
young for the but but
i asked my grandfather for the fourteen
dollars to go see him you would have
thought i asked for that [ __ ]
like can i buy the house right next door
to each other forever and ever and i
mean he just kind of like it was just
like i'm not going to give it to you i'm
not going to give it to you
and then he gave it and then he gave it
to me and then i ended up becoming
friends with those guys
that's amazing that's beautiful was
there like a whole culture of kiss fans
was it like deadheads and stuff [ __ ]
completely oh we should do an episode on
them
and have you on
on
well i i do think it's interesting that
like around the 70s as soon as the word
cult acquired this like aggressively
negative connotation the word also
became cool and that's why you have
words like cult followed and cult
classic because it it emerged during the
same culture of like rocky horror
picture show and the grateful dead and
fish
yeah and face troops
yeah fish fish heads is that what
they're called
really so i just like learned about fish
to like talk about what was everywhere
as well no no no no no no i lost my
that's a big thing i lost my virginity
i lost my virginity to somebody from
fish i mean there's a lot of bands out
there oh no right so somebody who
followed fish if i had lost my virginia
[Laughter]
i would be damaged
i'm a young man
and look at the poster in the back right
oh you love it thank you so much
[Music]
i mean
it's a full circle like to me that's oh
yeah
you know paul stanley is having his
seventh birthday party next month and i
got invited to that but if i'm in the
cult i'm still
and i never felt like i was gonna
well i left them when they went disco in
the 80s but
you have your boundaries nothing makes
me feel like i'm 14 then to go see him
and that's confetti's coming down and
i'm done a lot of stuff in my life but
it just it yeah like it just makes me
feel good i mean by bonnie taylor swift
whatever it's like
another drive-by taylor swift i like
don't look at
you know if you went back would you
would you hold out maybe
for someone but no but it was no he was
kidding he was a nice yeah
yeah yeah whatever we don't have to talk
about it but um it's my fault but i
think that's the feeling that i think
we're all chasing like that feeling
where we like returned and especially
now after the pandemic i think so i mean
nobody could nobody could go i'm looking
to lose my virginity you couldn't go
anywhere yeah everything was closed so
if you wanted to go somewhere you
couldn't go because everything was
closed yeah that's how i act that's how
i acted about like the first time i like
hooked up with someone after the
pandemic it was like almost like losing
my virginity i
oh my god well i think actually back to
the
stuff wow
did you get that shirt was that shirt in
your trunk right before you got here no
the loneliness and the isolation that we
all felt during covet is part of what
gave cuenon such power you know because
we were turning to these sort of
radicalized groups online to fulfill to
fill those voids yeah let's talk about
anti-vaxxers like backs versus
anti-backs
cult
who
who are who are the anti-baxters like
are they is it are they all republicans
are they just is there is there
i mean i feel like they're not all
republicans but
like the
venn diagram i feel like amanda loves
venn diagrams it doesn't fall democrat
though right well the population of
anti-vaxxers that i'm very interested in
um or not even
parties but just the proof yeah yeah no
i think okay so i'm i'm very interested
in conspiracy which is a portmanteau of
conspiracy theorists and spirituality
and it describes this like word
you guys don't report on toast i didn't
know
a hybrid word like brunch or frenemy
what is it portmanteau it's like two
words combined into each other like
brunch or hangry
fun fact
yeah i didn't know the reason i
mentioned it is because i didn't know
what a portmanteau was until i met him
it's word play it's wordplay what is
what what is it though it's like when
you combine combination of two words
yeah when you combine two words like
lunch and breakfast and it's brunch
so my daughter was hangry this morning
she was angry because she was hungry and
she hadn't had anything to eat
angry angry or mansplain is prominent
and explains we don't have to explain
that yeah yeah we know but um yeah so
many levels of irony
but uh yeah but but conspiracy is is a
combination of the words conspir or the
phrase conspiracy conspiracy theory with
spirituality and it describes this like
emerging group of people who believe in
the core tenet of conspiracy theories
that there's like an evil cabal of
global elites controlling the
socio-political order but who also
believe this new age idea that we're on
the brink of a paradigm shift or a great
awakening so these are our people who
like on the surface make no sense like
this boho
like girl who just came from bali who
kind of believes in like
uh the idea that um like celebrities are
sex trafficking
children in wayf like these sort of
really sort of like in selly i know i
keep saying that we like overuse the
word insult i don't think we understand
what it is
[Music]
which means it's very angry man yeah
yeah or somebody that's hooking up gets
off the list like you're on the list and
you're like [ __ ] man yeah well then i
got something i gotta hook up and get
off the list well then there's also like
vault cells who are like voluntary in
whatever the [ __ ] so anyway like there
are these people who on the surface seem
kind of like almost these like feminist
boho yogi ladies but also hold these
very conservative right-wing kind of
violent ideologies and this is like the
community of anti-vaxxers that i find
interesting and that thrives on the
internet you should be teaching at the
college level i could see you
in front of a class of people talking
this stuff really the university is one
of them
but also there's nothing that you could
say to somebody
logically to change their mind like
they're so [ __ ] right
they would they would not listen to you
and go you know what you're you know
what
okay i'm gonna tell you right now that
you i'm gonna think about what you like
there no but from the [ __ ] time you
open your mouth they're like i don't
give a [ __ ] what you're gonna tell me
yeah you're not gonna change my mind
especially i feel like once we got to
the point where like restaurants were
like requiring it for you to go inside
at least in la it's like if that if like
going out with your friends didn't
change your mind
then like what is going to change your
mind you know and and like don't get me
wrong like i i get a little scared like
before i get a vaccine you know it's
like stabbing your arm with something
that you don't know what it is but it's
like
doing your own research that also is
just like non-existent and those people
are just on reddit like that's not
research but i think it's funny when
people are so anti-vaxxed but they're
like eating carl's jr or like putting
things in their body that they are
literally doing drugs
like a lot of people who are anti-vaxxed
like do hard drugs oh my god that's like
this girl i used to work with who um
didn't believe in master mester and
weddison whoa spoonerism who didn't
believe in western medicine
so she like wouldn't take an advil on
her period but her face was like blown
up with botox and juvederm i'm like you
don't make sense oh yeah they get sick
they won't take the vaccine but yet
they'll go to the doctor when they're
sick but
what's on the
but also
the what's on the outside
became more important than what's on the
inside so true so you're trying to turn
back the clock which nobody can and
clearly
you know you're gonna get older but you
nobody wants to
but instead you're more concerned with
this than being
compassionate or
a or someone kind like you know on the
way over here
uh you see someone some woman by herself
homeless and this country doesn't take
care of anybody who's [ __ ] old like
they just turned their so true
back to you they starve they freeze to
death and it shouldn't it shouldn't they
shouldn't be
true
and we drive by and [ __ ] dark windows
and you're like yeah
it's [ __ ] it's crazy right yeah yeah
and i feel like those people because the
injections that they're getting like the
botox and stuff are affecting their
physical appearance they don't take into
account like this chemical effects that
they have inside of their body because
they're literally so shallow that their
thoughts don't do go deeper and i feel
like how it could affect their health
so they don't question botox but they
question the vaccine i think that
outside inside metaphor can also apply
to like the culture of the anti-vaxx
movement if you want to label it that is
more important to these people than the
actual facts and these facts are hard to
understand like
i don't oh my god whenever i like think
i'm gonna choke on my own spit i'm also
like the scientologists
are poisoning me but like yeah but i but
like i don't fully understand a lot of
these ideas either but like
i'm at least willing to admit my lack of
knowledge or my lack of understanding
and defer to the people who do know more
but they're so committed to this
community of anti-vaxxers and what it
stands for and the politics of it that
the actual facts like couldn't matter
less as you were saying or or you know i
remember somebody had a joke that said
you know there's people that think the
space program is fake and wrestling is
real like you know
them like you know i was doing playing
the golf tournament in south carolina
and there was these rebel flags at this
gas station liquor store and the guy
that was driving is african-american cop
from atlanta and i said hey tony we're
going to go in that that store sometime
this weekend he's like we're not going
in there sir that store we don't belong
you don't belong in there i don't belong
in there and by the outside rebel flags
and and they sell
ammunition
you get gas and so on sunday we're
coming back and we and i go we're going
in there you had a couple of drinks you
know the golf course we go in there and
i walk into the bell rings and the thing
and it just goes quiet you know and i'm
like hey how's everybody doing just
quiet
and this little dude that looked like
the 1000 bc guy like a big-ass beard
you know big [ __ ] hair
and he's just like this and he goes are
you george lopez and i said i am and he
goes if you're george lopez you know on
your show when you dropped out of
college and and you told your wife you
were going to college but you didn't go
where did you go i said i went to go hit
golf ball so that [ __ ] guy jumped in
there
it's him and they all came out
oh like he had he needed you to answer
the question correctly if i knew because
he didn't believe
is racism [ __ ] just
can [ __ ] be switched because if
you're famous the guy yeah
the way he looks right turns out to be
the guy that you think he is 69 i signed
to go back to vietnam and fight because
in 69 i was in georgia
and if you stepped off base they had at
that time they're still segregated
so they had whites only coloreds blacks
oh my gosh i said send me back i'd
rather be first gunner i got shot got
shot in the back in vietnam
him and i couldn't walk down the street
together i said no send me back to
vietnam i'd rather be fight this in the
united states i grew up in are we still
in that place yeah we are here yes by
color
the way people look
of their [ __ ] economic [ __ ] value
and their you know how they
if there's mental [ __ ] people that
are mentally ill on the streets it's
like there's too many people out there
it's not safe
and it's all adults you know it's
supposed to be like the greatest country
in the world yeah here's i did santa
claus you know parades on floats and
coming in on fire engines and stuff
and i got called by a reporter asked me
we're doing an article on uh santa's of
color what do you think about santas of
color
and i said
don't ask me about santas of color
because santas are for children and
children don't see color
adults see color
kids see santa claus that's all they see
yeah and it doesn't matter what color
they are that's so true and they were
doing art so don't don't include me in
your because i don't believe in it
and it's just sad that that's where it
does everything has an angle you know
nothing
it's like good you remember carlos
santana you know we were talking one
time and he said
you know i'm thinking about doing this
tranquility channel and he like puts it
on his tv and i'm like i'm gonna watch
his [ __ ] and all of a sudden i'll
just you know 40 minutes go by and i'm
just like this is pretty [ __ ] cool
it's just sunrises and water and a
tractor going it just and they do they
do it they they they have it all our
screen savers from apple is that [ __ ]
you know yeah
and and and he did it before anybody did
it and i thought there's no way anybody
[ __ ] but you know what some that that's
what we need unless
you know texting while driving and
and you know [ __ ]
telling somebody that you love them
instead of calling them or
saying you know like everything you do
everything by text
yeah i think
yeah i believe
it's removed like this removes you know
yeah i feel like the internet
like makes everyone think they know
everything and it's like really
unfortunate because so many people were
raised wrong so instead of leaning into
learning and being open-minded and
like being open-minded to like change
and not just what their parents taught
them they amanda talks about this a lot
they they search and they do their own
research because they think they're
scientists but then they're only
researching in their algorithm and so
the internet feeds them what they
already know and it makes it 10 times
worse and their confirmation bias does
the work for them you know
what's the algorithm people don't know
what an algorithm is
oh gosh how to explain that
everybody has a phone kids have phones
right computer science technology
i i joke that the algorithm is like the
only god i've ever known the algorithm
the ultimate cult leader i think the
best way to describe it is like with
tick tock like an algorithm is like like
i have before i even made a tick tock
account i made i i downloaded the app
but i didn't log in and so i was on the
home page just scrolling and some videos
i would like some videos i would skip
and so the algorithm started learning it
started learning what i like and what i
don't like and then it started feeding
me the videos that i enjoyed more and so
now my algorithm
it it knows me better than i know myself
it's true well i think like in its most
basic terms an algorithm doesn't
necessarily have to be that nefarious i
think an algorithm is like technology's
way or or even a person's way of
optimizing the best solution to
something so there's like an algorithm
for treating cancer that is like
determined by humans with the help of
like technology and such but like the
there's an algorithm for solving a math
problem and then there's an algorithm
for keeping you on tick tock for 1600
hours and also when you're on tick tock
you're not lying so it's your honest
self right
yeah you really like it exactly because
there's no audience right you're
privately liking your likes are private
like no one knows like what you like and
no one can look you know how like on
instagram when it says like oh this post
has like 500 likes you can click the 500
likes and see who's liked
[Music]
[Applause]
so are you scared that someone's going
to log into your tick tock and see who
you really are via your for you page uh
my my likes are private so the
algorithms are the algorithm that's one
thing but then what you post is what you
post different than what you like and
dislike i think so yeah we have two
things yes i'm looking right now for
a new car
for my wife
and so you look up one kind of car
yeah
yeah now start sending me car
dealerships
you know it just
that's what it's doing it knows that i'm
looking for a car so now it's sending me
all kinds of car dealers that's that's a
[ __ ] trip isn't it yeah it's like
somebody it's like having a relative
that's [ __ ] pointing you you want on
your car how about looking over here
look at this i'm still trying to figure
out what algorithm got all the new new
photos that's the one how did i get all
this stuff all that foot google yeah
what's the cult of um yeah let's talk
about elon musk yeah yeah let's talk
about elon musk
for people that might not for people
that don't know that very that much
about him like today i think he said you
know i'm going to pay 11 billion dollars
in taxes this year he said but he has
100 billion i don't know what the [ __ ]
the cultist thing about elon musk to me
is just the fact that like is he a
scientist right so what is he no this is
what i was a rich white boy
like
he is right yeah he's a brilliant dude
yeah he's a brilliant dude i would say
the cultist thing about elon musk to me
is that people think he has access to
this transcendent almost spiritual
wisdom like he is not just a business
person in the way that like 30 years ago
we would be bored to hear a business
person talk he's like a business person
meets self-help guru meets spiritual
leader meets influencer meets celebrity
he's all these things yeah who would
have been that's what i'm sorry
i
guess because we were talking about it
the reason i think he's problematic is
because what is he first and foremost
he's a businessman right and
historically when you see businessmen
they stay in their lane they like you
know like
bill gates he's not a public figure
intentionally he's a businessman and
he's a billionaire and he does his
professional stuff but elon musk is very
intentional about being a public figure
as well celebrity and that's dangerous
because when he tweets something that
affects like the market
and so the reason i think that's
dangerous is because now not only does
he have financial power but he also has
like
uh societal power which is like really
important like he can change people's
idea like a mentality about what planet
they want to live on like yeah so you
have people that wake up and they follow
them and they and they're they're like a
cult like like my dad is in the cult of
elon musk where you're reading what he
does he tweets you
like i don't want to formulate you're
like i don't want to formulate an
opinion about this until i hear what
elon has to say yeah which is like you
know that that that holds a type of
religious power when you're not basing
certain profound life decisions um on
what you think or like this vast amalgam
of influences you're basing it just on
what this one soul person has to say
so ultimately do you think that people
want to be told what to do and what to
think so that they don't make the wrong
decision because some people say like
hey listen
you know that's my private thing i'll
take care of it but overall almost like
the algorithm is you want somebody to
be right for you like yeah like if you
do this that's why amanda watches
youtube when she's high because she's
like take me away take it away no but
true true
you're you're in a [ __ ] another oh
yeah you're you know you're the mind is
the most powerful and you're in another
place yeah i think it's
there's particularly a lot of pressure
right now
to
come up with like um so many you have to
come up with so many answers to so many
more questions than we had in our lives
50 years ago or even 30 years ago now
there are just like almost limitless
possibilities for what direction our
lives can go in it's like who like you
were saying before like when you were
growing up there wasn't so much personal
style everybody kind of dressed the same
way and that wasn't great for some
reasons but like for other reasons
people knew
people knew their life purpose yeah and
now it's like where am i going to live
what's my job going to be what's my hair
going to look like almost like a house
will the world be here yeah yeah have
you guys heard of like decision
exhaustion i think that's what it's
called it's scissors paradise yeah it's
like today even when you choose this
paradox when you go to the grocery store
let's say you want corn flakes
diced but not a pair of dogs
like something as simple as like going
to the grocery store and getting corn
flakes you're like oh should i get the
kellogg's branch should i get the target
brand should i get the walmart brand
should i get like you have like all of
these brands in front of you and even
that is a really hard decision to make
so so people get attached to a brand
early on
uh in their lives and they they
buy the same thing their whole life well
i was actually learning um in some of my
research for the book that millennials
and young people are less br less brand
loyal than any previous generation
because we're like
savvier we're more interested in um in
brands that like have a mission
connection like this isn't just a beer
it's a beer that donates to this
organization and this is a beer that
makes me a certain type of person um but
yeah i think exactly like we have
choosers paradox and we just want
someone to tell us who to be what to
think like we want an identity template
for like how do we be in who's
who we be it's why at the end of the day
when we wa when after like being at work
and making all these decisions all day
people come home and then they just like
succumb to their phone yeah like okay
so
um i i know a woman that that her
husband is like
they're very like their marriage is just
really staying together but from the
time that dude gets home he goes in a
room and he plays a computer game for
like the next [ __ ] seven hours like
he's at work eight hours he comes home
he plays
to [ __ ] in the middle of the night
and
at the expense of a relationship with
his kids and his wife and and the gamers
like people that do yeah like what it
what what is i mean what type of person
is like i i grew up alone like i was an
only child i never really got into the
the things where you played on the game
or your tv that reminds me though of
like i don't know what the word is and
maybe amanda will know but there's this
word where like
you stay up later at night because like
on the phone or like watching tv even
though like you would be more rested
after a long day of work you would be
more arrested going home and going to
sleep at like 9 00 p.m if you get home
at like 8 p.m after a long day of work
you still watch like three hours of tv
even though it's less sleep because you
want to feel in control
to relax yes you know spiteful autonomy
or
the way but even somebody would say like
you know
they say i can't go like there's a guy
that i know that says i can't sleep
unless the tv is on it and it's like
that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
because you know
like how did this how did the stone age
people fall asleep
like the dude is like he remember that
vienna coffee that that swiss coffee
that they don't even make it anymore um
what the name of that like they had all
these viennese coffees yeah like that
and he went and bought like a thousand
[ __ ] containers of it because every
morning at night he drinks it like
forever yeah and they don't make it
anymore so he
bought
a lifetime supply
so
i think that's actually related to the
video game thing because i think we are
very comforted by ritual whether it's
like a religious ritual or a secular
ritual or like a silly ritual it does
make us feel like connected to something
larger than ourselves it makes us feel
like we're reclaiming our own life if we
can like do this thing that feels kind
of sacred yeah i do think though it's
very funny like americans will be like
oh they speak about themselves like it's
factual they're like oh i literally will
not be able to go to sleep and it's like
when was the last time you drank coffee
and they were like i drink a coffee
every night at 9 00 pm yeah and it's
like [ __ ]
that's why you can't sleep
they think they're more powerful than
caffeine yeah yeah mine can you know and
then
but then it it perpetuates where all of
a sudden now
if you do it you you won't go to sleep
you get home at seven you won't go to
sleep till two in the morning exactly it
like stays in your system coffee like i
every i drink coffee every day but every
like
four to six weeks i have to take like a
week break from coffee because i feel it
accumulating in my body and then like
it's starting to affect my like sleep
schedule and my anxiety and so i have to
like do like a whole week without coffee
where i just have like horrible
headaches but then at the end of the
week i feel like way better because my
anxiety and my sleep habits are way more
normal i'm starting to get tired where
did anxiety come from
did it come from miner
no no why well i think if we figure out
where it came from yeah you're like
we can zone in on you i'll start with it
but but
when we were growing up i don't think
there was anybody that had
i think by choices by
you know the amount of time if you're in
line waiting to get something and
they're like can i help you and you're
like uh i
uh yeah that's true it has to be
everything has to be so fast like you
don't i think it's a combination of
destigmatizing mental health like
talking about it and also
the pace at which our world is moving
now like you said like back in the day
you know like people who are working it
wasn't about like maximum output maximum
production it's like if you went to a
coffee shop and it took you an extra
three minutes to order your coffee
people just had to wait and it wasn't
the end of the world but now it's like
everyone has somewhere to be everyone
has something to do everyone thinks that
they're like the most important person
in the world yeah and so i think that
adds to anxiety because we're all on
this like ticking time bomb of like i
only have so much time and i need to do
it it does feel like the end of the
world will come if like i don't get this
instagram post up in the next one second
you know it's like i'm on a different
train you know
i really don't like that
but also i'm very relaxed i don't push
things you know i i'm not in a big hurry
the only thing i'm in a big hurry for
make sure i'm on time for george but
other than that yeah i really don't care
take time you know
i'm trying to slow down like i heard
that time feels slower when you're in
nature
time for your time feels slower when
you're doing things with your hands like
screen time flies by
but if you played basketball yesterday
for like an hour i was like wow this is
blast
so present the hour felt like three
because you can't play basketball we
weren't just no no i was
yeah i was wearing running well i was
gonna go for a long walk and then i
walked by the park and a bunch of dudes
were playing basketball and i was like
that looks really fun so i walked to
target i bought a basketball and then i
walked back to the park and then i
played for like an hour and i was like
seize the day man you played by yourself
yeah all right yeah we shot hoops i did
i felt so cool i was like no wonder men
are confident they just play basketball
out in the public yeah it's a dollar
morning i think there is a
well that's another good question like a
sense of accomplishment if you're
playing basketball and you shoot it and
you start making them yeah then you
start to it's almost like um
i played go i started i played golf i've
been playing golf for a long time and
golf
all the things that were wrong with me
growing up
were exposed by golf you know i would
quit
temper i'd get mad and i had no patience
and uh my high school coach told me that
you know
i was gonna be nothing because i quit
when [ __ ] got tough and after i started
playing golf i [ __ ] realized that he
was right like i quit and i was driving
home and it's almost like in those
movies where you can see like the head
talking yeah
george you quit
and i pulled over your coach was right
yeah i [ __ ] went over to the school i
hadn't been there like in five years and
i went and apologized to him and he was
like where did this come like i'd never
done that before wow but also
i'd never apologized to anybody really
like that but also i don't think i could
have continued my life
had i not said i was sorry to him which
was also very meaningful in my life like
i never said i can't live if i don't
tell this dude that i'm if that guy
started a cult would you follow it
yeah
i don't think so but
but he was right but high school coaches
could start cultural oh a thousand
percent but also he was [ __ ] dead
like he wasn't saying i was ugly yeah he
was saying you were a [ __ ] quitter
yeah he was yeah that's the truth that's
big on you that you went back in
apologies like bullying bullying is let
me say oh you [ __ ] big eared
[ __ ] like that's different but
they go hey at least i'm not the one
that can't [ __ ] sit somewhere and and
just be casual for five minutes without
having to look at their phone and you're
like yeah gosh yeah yeah no that was
that was real feedback that he gave you
he did give great feedback yeah whenever
i get real feedback is hard
but you know it's real but i know it's
real i can take it
have you been doing stand-up now uh
three years including the pandemic so
like
i was at a year in i was at about a year
when the pandemic hit and so now i've
been doing it for like were some of your
early influences oh great question
um i mean in like the in a lot of women
like ali wong
was one of my favorite comedians um
uh amy schumer i i just kind of go with
the big names usually
um of women but uh because well because
for me it was like it was i didn't
really i was introduced to stand up by
kind of like by netflix like when like
when they started to give women big
specials i was like oh women can do this
in like a stadium
and then that's when i started to get
into it and then i got immediately into
like the independent comedy scene in
like la and so like a lot of my
influences like i don't know if like
chase bernstein is like a small comedian
in la but i love her she's so funny um
like and it's just like smaller
comedians would i be somebody like a
walmart of comedians like somebody that
everybody knows well i was going to say
of course no no no not of course me but
you know i i didn't start out as a
walmart started out just as a little guy
yeah i was going to say in terms of like
your show that was like formative in my
life you know like i watched that show
all the time growing up yeah um and
honestly like i feel like it's
they haven't made anything like it i
think for like latino like it's almost
20 years but you know um i had like um
you know manifest destiny i think is you
know where you can make things um
when
you carry you know i love drew carey
juke lived in his car he did a tonight
show and johnny carson asked him to come
over to the couch and he was a bit he
got a show on abc and he was like
top five shows and i would just be like
[ __ ] man and and
he did the show with bruce halford and i
would tell my wife i would say like
where's where's my bruce helper like
where's the guy
that's gonna help me you know and i
never thought i had a show and then i
got bruce alford
and we did that first show
and in that first show
they usually don't make a first-time
comedian like a creator on a show
but
i
saw tim allen before he did home
improvement and everything is in their
act you know everything's like your book
everything is you want to know about
something is in there and i remember
sitting back there thinking this [ __ ]
guy is just [ __ ] amazing and it's all
about the one thing like two weeks yeah
like that big moment big thing and i was
back there i said man i don't have that
i don't have that and uh in the 90s
somebody gave me some constructive
criticism which i'd listened to it
changed the way i did my
work and nine years after that i had my
show and in the beginning
i would tell them stories and the girl
would be typing and you know some were
funny you know my way my grandmother was
and the way that my family was and then
i would start crying a little bit and
she would look up and she would be like
are you all right and they would say you
want to stop i go no no no i'll just
keep going it'll be funny and
in all of that it did like the sad and
the things that were that were bad about
me and my grandmother the mom
like they all became funny like from
that you could make something funny yeah
and
and bruce and the other guy robert went
to the president at warner brothers and
said hey man you're i know we don't
really make creators out of like first
time guys but without his input we don't
have a show like we it's not we're not
writing it we're listening to him and
that's
what that happened so you know as
comedians go and try to be
you know um
overall accepted there is
in the nuance is where the [ __ ]
yeah future and where your heart and
your soul is not like not being like i
can see it in you and i can see it in
you that
the nuance is the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
people are attracted to now no it's true
i feel like it is
like it was those big moments of female
comedians that like attracted me but
it's now what keep
kept me in the cult of stand-up comedy
is like seeing the people live in small
rooms seeing them in like backyards and
like workshop their material and
especially like as a new comedian you
really have to prove yourself and get to
the punch line very quickly because
people don't give you like the time but
i love seeing a comedian
workshop their new material and they're
just telling a story and telling a story
and somehow they form this like whole
arc and then they get to the punch line
and it's just like 10 times sweeter and
i'm like that's what kept me but
everybody has their own formula in their
own in their self like some guys you
know try to be like a person or
derivative of somebody but it if you
spend the time doing it
it all appears you know it's all kind of
like if you see the stars now come to
one thing they all kind of gravitate to
what's yeah what's in the heart and soul
yeah i think this
is
so emotional
we love an earnest moment yeah but but
you know i i was you know poor and then
you know we start to do that stuff and
then you know everything the last 20
years it's almost 20 years have been
crazy
and
even sometimes you know i still hang out
with the guys i hang out with but i
i see myself different grown up but i
still see like whatever in protecting
the flame you know like the olympic
flame never goes out yeah the fire is
still on like it does and i've seen some
guys where you see people where
it's kind of going through the motions
and and it's almost going and seeing
magic like you can if you see how they
do the trick you it's not magic yeah but
in stand-up when you see somebody that
like you say workshopping somebody but
that they still care about what they do
it's you know yeah yeah you can tell
yeah you can also definitely tell when
people care i don't care oh you know
it's like
very obvious oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what time is it good
oh we still got like a half hour here oh
nice
there was a i mean we said about elon
musk like yeah we kind of but you know
but he hosted saturday night live and
didn't do well but you couldn't you
wouldn't expect them to do well oh i
mean what the [ __ ] like i mean this is
the guy from tesla oh yeah yeah and
everybody's like i mean this is just
like a side effect of him becoming this
suit of celebrity it's kind of like it
reminds me of like when a rich kid like
his parents pay for him to go to get
into the right college exactly and he
fails at the college he sucks he has
horrible grades it's like elon musk like
paid for that spot yeah you know he
didn't earn that spot yeah well i mean
it's just like not the right avenue for
him you know it like makes no sense kind
of
well he he's on the autism narcissist
yeah he's an autism well so right so
like i don't know if that has anything
to do with comedy but like
but the fact that he's like not a
performer has a lot to do with him
sucking sure sure i mean
but also
at no point did he say hey you know what
i'm i'm not a performer like i'll
come out and say a few things with that
is so true he owned it he was just like
here i am you worship me yeah yeah
and uh yeah it's not worthy of the
listen you ever see that document the
source family about this yeah
you know that dude tried to fly
in maui on a on a hang glider
and he broke his back and he was so
[ __ ] hot that he believed he could
fly yeah
yeah they they they were on to them here
and then they moved to maui and they
bought a bunch of property
restaurant a lot of people went to that
restaurant by the comedy store i think
it's baja cantina now
and
he had all these women all these kids
had instruments and it was a big thing
the natural thing all stevie nicks and
the joni mitchell everybody went over
there and then they got into this whole
cultic rolls-royce thing the guy in the
robes and then they got onto him
tax-wise here uh you know the kids and
all that stuff and they went to hawaii
and the guy literally thought he could
fly
and jumped off this [ __ ] canyon and
broke his back and he's like oh
oh my god and he died and it's just like
this guy he died it's literally the
icarus
story like straight up did you
completely change the people yeah i mean
i'm fascinated by like what what builds
up people's ego to that level like is it
society is it some underlying
personality disorder is it like a mental
health thing like is it a combination of
all three like i'm i'm fascinated
because sometimes people will ask me
like what's the difference between you
and a cult leader like you're trying to
get people to listen to your work and
like the second you start defending why
you're not a cult leader you instantly
sound like yeah yeah so i try to just
deflect but like in all people how to
think you're you're explaining
yeah i i don't mind if people linguists
yeah
she's telling them how to speak yeah
no i'm just i'm describing how people do
yeah um but yeah but i i don't know i
mean i think they're
i i am very interested in like
people who seem not to have like any
limits to the amount of power they want
yeah i wonder like because i feel like
before narcissism
like it was very clearly seen as like
kind of like this thing that like you're
born with it's like like this like
mental what is it what's the word mental
disorder disorder
yeah it's kind of like a mental disorder
that like you're born with or you're not
born with but with social media
i
wonder it's kind of like almost like
anxiety you know you're either born with
anxiety you're not born with anxiety but
you're born with narcissism you're not
born with narcissism but social media
has like put us in this other space
where like you can kind of get those
things from social media like people
start becoming they feel godlike and
what about filters like you you look at
what people can do with pictures
in a filter where you know they expose
you know koi kardashian or yes oh my god
well we i mean we also we're gonna yeah
i mean all of them can i say that when i
had my talk show i was
uh close you know very close with them
and and
i don't know if they might not we might
take it out but
i was flying to cleveland to do a show
on a red-eye and chloe got on the plane
and i looked at her and i looked away
and she goes
and i look back and she goes chloe and i
said oh hey i thought that was i [ __ ]
didn't even recognize i didn't recognize
that well i think what a lot of that
does because it was in person yeah i
think a lot of those filters and such
like help almost make us delude
ourselves like we forget what i don't
think they don't know i don't think they
know what they look like so true oh my
god wait can i tell a fun story about a
kardashian yes um okay in my former life
i worked as an editor at an online
beauty magazine that was another cult
i've conformed i had blonde hair it was
a whole [ __ ] thing online
okay yeah that picture would be blonde
oh gosh if you said that yeah whatever
whatever
but um there was this one time when i
was like shepherded in a big black suv
to uh the four seasons in westlake to
interview kourtney kardashian about um
some brand partnership that she was
doing and we talked about like skincare
for a while and then i asked if i could
get a picture of course you want the
selfie and she was like yeah one second
um
what's haroush or i forget where her
assistant's name is but she like called
over this assistant and we posed
together in a number of different like
lighting situations to get it perfect
and then the assistant was like do you
facetune on your phone and i was like
yeah and i handed my phone over and she
was like okay and and she like started
face tuning courtney for for me and my
like shitty little instagram and i was
like oh well
face tuned me too and she was like don't
worry
and she made my arm like half its size
courtney's waist came in like this and
her ass came out like this and uh to
come for us if this is public well i
mean i i think i actually included it in
my write-up but like i was just so
interested take a picture of gil and can
you facetune it
yeah
well
unfortunately i do know how to do this
now
but i was just amazed that like even the
kardashians don't look like the
kardashians yeah yeah yeah
i worry about like
we're gonna we're gonna
yeah i worry about like i mean you are
perfect but i can you are perfect but i
can make you look like it i have face
tuned by the way perfectly i have face
tunes i face two notes oh face
it's just it's like another app that you
can like mess with it's like to edit you
can photoshop
we're taking a picture and there i don't
know if i should do this fix me up no no
but but it's also it's not what was
there right in that room like they tuned
you up she tuned herself up yeah and all
of a sudden
it's out there and
even like
and i feel like that only
leans into that false narrative because
it was such a small picture like amanda
like at the time i don't know i maybe
had like no i may have had maybe like a
thousand instagram followers so it was
like if a person with just a thousand if
if this famous person looked perfect in
that random picture with this random
person
then that almost makes it more real but
also it's like
almost like in a sense fishing where if
you get somebody like that and you put
them on your account now all of a sudden
they draw people to you and they follow
you yeah
they're like you know right one's gonna
make me she's gonna make me look good
and people are gonna say okay
of course
but what on instagram when you you got
your blue dot right yeah
and then what were people telling you
like positive things or negative things
like i i don't look i don't read the
comments i don't i don't i i really
don't read that much and i'm afraid to
touch anything but just lie though eliza
told me
be careful don't touch any you know
don't link up because you don't have a
double security yet and we're supposed
to look up to give me the double
security oh yeah gotta get the two
factors that'll suck you know
just like text your phone so if like if
you're trying to log in oh you can do
that straight on your phone because
somebody will try it yeah we could set
it up for you right now come on
i have that up
how did you get verified on instagram
oh you don't have a blue dot no
blue dot no
you ever flew that you do yeah she's
like
yeah yeah i don't know it'll it'll be
there soon um uh yeah but you guys are
you do you guys think you're similar
in personality similar
we yeah i think we're like um amanda's
like
a lot of people i think i think we're
different flavors of the same popsicle
yeah i think well amanda's like
a little bit older than me i think she's
like more mature version of me
uh in a lot of ways yeah
but talk about my age that much for sure
no she's still yeah i don't know
no no we're not talking about age no i
think she's a little older than me
amanda's like me but elderly
but she looks younger than me so it's
not like it matters you know
look at her face oh stop i'm just doused
in makeup okay this is all i'm gonna do
for now i don't really know how to
toggle back and forth between i think
yeah i think we're i'm probably the more
like unhinged version okay i feel like i
feel like that track's just done oh
you see oh yeah
oh oh yeah
oh dude gil's got some delts in this one
now if you i don't know if you can even
see it okay okay you didn't do anything
to grab let me see no because you know
i'm perfect the way i am thanks george
well this is time consuming i mean this
is what i'm saying it's like toggle some
people waste okay
can you show him how to put stories on
yeah you want to send him this picture
here is the but i'm on instagram i mean
you're very kind you didn't do anything
so you did shoulders ah i just you know
you gotta show your mouth you gotta
carve out the shoulders
give like a nice filter on the face
oh yeah
but this will [ __ ] with you i mean this
is why teenage girls are miserable these
days is because they're not only
comparing themselves to like everyone in
the world they're comparing themselves
to like this perfected version of their
own body and face it's bucked
right or if you or if you put
something like you know
the thing with me the thing with me is
that like 20 years ago i was
40 i was like when the show started i
was 40 almost 41 42 so it's on every day
i'm in my 40s and i'm 60. so when people
see me they're like oh man like
way [ __ ] different i'm fascinated by
this especially with the internet it's
like you can discover someone's old self
so now if you like like from 10 20 30 40
years ago and then not realize that like
time moves even for famous people like
and you can only do so much to people
but they live in like that [ __ ] past
thing
and
it doesn't look good that you people
either
i know i know it's very disturbing and
like you know i mean this is probably
like a cult that i'm in like the cult of
just beauty standards you know like i i
mean the pandemic was actually good for
me in this regard because i
could couldn't access like a lot of the
beauty treatments that i had been doing
did you do that stuff i mean i was like
facials and stuff yeah i did all that
stuff especially when i was working at
that magazine like it was just in the
culture too dire hair get spray tans get
the eyelash extensions um and now i
don't really do that stuff anymore
because i was like reacquainted with
what i actually look like
yeah i know but but did you do it before
you worked at that magazine no and so
being in that world like fashion is
fashion right yeah so
yeah so you do what do your parents say
about spray tan stuff
everyone knew it
i had i had blonde hair everyone who
knew and loved me hated it
um they thought i like i didn't look
related to my family
it was disturbing um
yeah so i don't know but you almost like
you almost felt like you had to do it
like it's part
well you know
it's around so much similar to cult
influence it's like i felt conditioned
to want to do it i felt at times a
little bit coerced into doing it but at
the same time nobody had a gun to my
head like if i wanted to look more
natural i could have but like there's
this part of you that wants to conform
that wants to be like your best self
however that best self is being defined
by the group is is it like uh the devil
worst prada
well yeah it was like the la version of
that yeah you seen the devil with prada
no but you know we're saying i'm back to
that it's a great name by the way
i love that
i was just listening to the chris 103.5
lmk her show this morning
and she had a guest on there and they
were talking about
uh the female guest was talking about
the first time that she kissed her
new male friend
and it grossed her out because he stunk
he had this spray and he no longer does
he would spray on this tan stuff but it
really stopped the hi-hat yeah the fake
candles
horrible and she says here i thought
this was an italian guy come out here
you know real italian
i can smell that you are not not in l.a
nothing is real here it really grossed
me out so yeah yeah it's uncanny it's
like you're a human approximating a
human you're not really
look you know donald trump so he
he's orange yeah right
but he paints himself [ __ ] orange
like in this like yeah wide around here
yeah
so the people that follow him if you
follow him
i mean
he i mean he doesn't like immigrants his
wife doesn't speak english he you know
all his wife have been immigrants and
the the contradictions that he tries to
be
willing
like die for that guy and he could give
a [ __ ] about allegedly give a [ __ ] about
anybody but himself well and exactly but
then the odd part is that those people
like his sort of filterless say it like
it is honesty i think they think all
politicians don't care if i'm dead he's
just saying it out loud and i respect
that yeah i also think that
with uh americans love to think that
like they're the unique and they're the
special one and so if trump is hating on
everyone his fans i think think like but
it would be different for me
it would be different with me whereas
like with regular politicians they love
everyone and so they're like oh that's
not special then i'm not special and so
they like like that they're like they
could be the unique one but it's
delusional because trump doesn't like
anyone but at what point are comedians
held to a higher standard than
politicians
because i got two almost two years ago
next month i got a visit from the secret
servers over something that i said but
but if you look at what politicians say
their their words are more damaging like
were
it's ingest like you can't forget that
it's ingest or if somebody were to say
well you know that's not funny
so
like that's supposed to minimize this
yeah yeah but really they're it's the tr
we're speaking the truth right yeah well
politicians i think like
they're a lot of them are like literally
lawyers a lot of them are like you know
they have like more power under the law
so i think like what they say is
is allowed to be more scrutinized but
also they lived in that [ __ ] place
where they got elected they could be
there forever like i went to dc i talked
to a lobbyist and they were able to
throw money around and accept gifts and
do [ __ ] lobbyists around this country
there were lobbyists were it was like
being
a [ __ ] having your own [ __ ] laws
in your own country you could throw no
oh my god i always say um everyone
always talks about how latin american
countries are so corrupt and it's like
um
america what i'm like lobbying is legal
corruption well speaking of netflix cult
documentaries did you watch the family
no that's about this like evangelical
cult that puts on the national prayer
breakfast every single year remember
that oh yeah that is not way from where
yeah
is this now deceased like evangelical
maniac who like um is secretly
controlling politics in these really
disturbing ways yeah motivated by his
own interpretation of his of
christianity and right or whatever i
mean yeah politics yeah and they and and
generationally they held the same
beliefs as guys came up and
you know politicians were removed they
stayed on the same by the same almost
like finding that that book almost like
you know and there's some movie where
like how to talk to a girl they find
that book it's like it's the book like
50 years later yeah yeah follow the
rules oh yeah it's this yeah obviously
like incredibly misogynistic like you
know macho
way of looking and and approaching the
world um but i think speaking to like
why people hold comedians sometimes to a
higher standard than politicians is i
think in part because of
uh certain biases like where we we think
of politicians as sort of like evil like
a lot of us do and so we think like well
of course they said this terrible thing
but a comedian like we look at them with
stars in our eyes i think that's
such a new thing though you know what i
mean like i feel like
now that comedian
i think it falls under the umbrella of
like
entertainment people in entertainment
celebrity actors writers there's this
whole like movement around hollywood
that is generally liberal you know like
people are mostly like for
you know equality and human rights and
like that's what like that's what
people you know people talk about in
their speeches
so people hold comedians under that
umbrella of like oh like
you should be for the right thing that's
why they hold them to a higher you know
tim allen's show was on you know i know
tim allen for a long time and you know
his show was on abc and then it got
cancelled and he he came out and said i
think other kinds because i'm i'm right
a right-wing guy and then it ended up at
the fox network for like another four or
five years
yeah almost and that rarely had like
that rarely happens yeah and they just
finished last year but but
you know i'm i know him i'm friends with
him our politics are different the one
that's crazy is you know i grew up going
to see ted nugent all the time and then
he becomes this [ __ ] we'll get him on
here okay uh and uh
i posted a picture
because i met you know i met him 12
years ago and then we became friends
kind of friends and and they're like oh
[ __ ] you be friends with that guy
you're a [ __ ] chicano you're a latino
and this guy's over here but it's like
it's about the music it's not about yeah
i i respect his politics and he respects
mind it's like whatever but if i wanted
to hate him you could hate him for his
politics but not for the music i grew up
with the music but remember politics
used to be like based on policy and not
like wanting certain people to literally
die yeah
there's definitely like a line yeah i
feel like with the second election with
the second trump election like the first
trump election like i have a friend who
voted for trump in the first election
and he's like a gay man and so we were
all shocked oh he also told me like
three months after the election so
i like confess
but it was a big deal it's a big deal
yeah yeah and but and that was the first
election i think by the time the second
election came around
for me it was like harder to see eye to
eye with those people but um well also
but if you know that you subscribe like
if you believe that if you believe what
he believes and you're with that then
it's co it's
exactly and trump is different from like
republicans
i don't know i don't know what it was
like in your home
i i do know that politics were never
spoken to my home growing up
at all never never never
and i remember
my dad was deceased
and i'm a working cop and when i came
out of the army and you know when i went
into the army i was 17 years old then i
registered to vote
and i registered as a democrat because
all i was ever taught that i thought
democrats were always for the poor
people
and i was one of them poor ones
so i went on now years later my dad's
passed away i'm in my late 20s my mom
asked me hey
what do you think about this thing right
here i said mom maybe you ought to ask
one of my sisters and she said what do
you mean why why why won't you answer i
said well i'm a registered republican
now you know i registered democrat when
i first now i'm registered republican
and you know that answer
getting on a sense from one of my
sisters
and she said
are you kidding me well that's a
doctor's office okay
wait no i'm gonna wait
uh well
i'll just put her
he's just trying to sell you medication
you don't need
they're reminding me i have an
appointment tomorrow that's all they're
doing
uh so
i told my mom and my mom just said and
what's wrong with that you're a
republican
and my dad was a laborer all his life
and
and i said well because i'm republican
my dad was a dem
says what made you think your dad was a
democrat
hmm
yeah and so we had never talked about it
she says
your dad used to say if i got to work it
sounds like seeing them in heels being
like well
[Laughter]
he just said hey if i got to work and
pay
for everything so should they i'm tired
of giving free listen every time tax
season comes around i'm like am i a
republican no have you ever like
accidentally like put the wrong address
on your amazon like one time i i was
ordering something from amazon and i put
my parents address in virginia and then
i was like oh shoot i need to change it
to my address in california and the tax
was like three times as expensive and i
was like god damn it yeah
but
but nobody ever spoke politics or
religion no they didn't in my house and
in that time of the last six seven years
people were [ __ ] killed at
thanksgiving dinner over
over political beliefs like yeah you
started [ __ ] fighting yeah yeah
we talked about it a lot in my family
for me it wasn't talked about because
like we became citizens my sophomore
year of college so we couldn't vote
before you know what i mean yeah so it
was like my dad would watch cnn all the
time and like but it but he it was more
like a hobby like it wasn't like oh it's
not like you could do anything about it
because you couldn't vote but also
people would vote on pictures and vote
on videos but not
vote in an election yeah and that's what
i think the the red counted on was that
the democrats you know had the low voter
turnout yeah you know right because
younger people tend to be left and
younger people tend not to vote and they
would always vote so they go well by
sheer like we're our votes are our votes
we we're gonna know that there's a
certain portion of of them that are not
gonna show up and you know my
grandmother was born in el centro
uh california and i never talked to her
about this but from the time that i
turned 18
she voted in every election we grown up
and then by the time i turned 18 she
voted in every election and she would
call me and say
make sure you go vote and there wasn't
really a lot of things that she was kind
of that right striding about yeah the
elections were them and i'm like yeah
there was a trip from her life and the
other you said it didn't have politics
or religion uh my dad was not a real
religious man
but my mom told me that the only time he
went to church every sunday was what i
was in vietnam
that's the only time and when i came
back
and that's why you're here today
but like it's comforting you know it's
happening yeah my family we talked about
um religion and politics a lot mostly
because my parents my parents were like
ugh religion but the other but the but
you know i mean can you get by without
it i think you can right
well i still pray on every flight yeah i
mean they they drive by my house today
he went like this
i
i guess he was starting the trip they
had like kids in the they packed oh my
dad does that too uh on on long road
trips yeah he does so interesting well i
do it on flight my parents like have
this low grade distain for religion but
they still brought me up kind of jewish
but um but my my dad's side of the
family i mean this is kind of important
[Laughter]
kind of jewish um but but but
but to bring it like all the way full
circle like my my dad's side saw the
family they were card carrying
communists and in the late 60s my dad's
like absentee father and
new wife joined this socialist cult
and my dad was 14 so he had to go with
them and hearing those stories of my
dad's experiences on this like socialist
utopian compound are part of what like
planted the seeds of my interesting
culture yeah because there's like the i
mean there's horseshoe theory right like
the extremes of both political parties
end up in kind of a similar place it's
like that snl sketch republican or not
it's like are you wearing camo because
you love the military or because you're
trying to look like rihanna yeah yeah
you know what she you said it i mean
here we are we went around and we did
two hours and we come back and it is it
is a horse shoe i love the horseshoe
because of what what he did you went
yeah it's like almost when sometimes
you're so gay you're straight
[Laughter]
i'm gonna think about
but you know people know people are gay
or they say oh i'm gay where before
nobody said i'm gay you assumed if
someone was
yeah you're not yeah right
now i'm like so the things that were i
mean as we evolve or or or unravel as
you go the things that people held
private are almost your calling card
totally i mean yeah culture is changing
for better and for worse it's like
facetune is ruining our lives but now
you can be gay and not like get killed
all the time yeah you know
i don't think i've been as i've been a
little profound but you know
this these two hours here
they've been great
i mean really really [ __ ] great yeah
thank you very much
have you not enjoyed it i have i am
yeah thank you so much for having me so
would you consider yourself uh i will
make this offer to you tomorrow i am uh
doing the laugh factory in hollywood i
sold out that factory oh so and i would
like to offer you a spot if you feel you
want to take it i
would love to take it i will cancel my
flight
right away it's again
i'll cancel it unless you're doing it
some other time
i mean now i'll cancel it
i don't really do a lot of shows in l.a
she's obviously not that committed to
this place no i have commitment issues
but he'll be there
you'll probably he probably goes but you
don't i will
push the flight i can get credit you
know i don't really do shows in l.a
you know other the theater
over there but these kind of things are
kind of just pop-up things yeah no i
would love to i will be there
yeah that's fine i'll come watch let's
do it there you go all right all right
well we can feed you there
yeah
cool
you know i didn't know anything about
fashion growing up you know and i was
momo rodriguez come here i sent him some
i got some gucci gucci sneakers for
christmas and he goes i could get used
to this
you forget you forget when you when you
grow up you know buying [ __ ] at jcpenney
or kmart or white front or zodies
wherever still buying a sketcher and you
forget that
that some people around this world make
some really nice [ __ ] yeah that's true
you know like you're just like what is
that uh
yeah
again if the scientologists want to send
me on vacation and i will accept
no
i'll send you on vacation
no strings attached you and your man no
strings attached you don't have to come
back
and clean out that thing on franklin you
know but you know
i drive by
the celebrity cent center yeah and um
they own the build they want a lot of
stuff they want a building across the
street
and
on sunset on franklin and like over
there by gelsons
and there is
zero activity outside or anybody hanging
around or talking outside because that
building i think they they bought and it
was kind of like an older maybe trans
not trans but older yeah older people
then they bought it and immediately they
fixed it up so it's it looks way
different but also the shades are all
drawn and you never see anybody else
it's so crazy
yeah i mean speaking of politics like i
remember looking at a map like when the
last election was happening um where you
could see like pretty regularly like
neighborhood by navy neighborhood what
in la was blue and what was red and it
was like all blue except for beverly
hills and this one little sliver this
one little triangle in hollywood it was
the church of scientology just like this
their property they're like 477 000
square foot property they have a lot of
they they have so much problems
that they don't need to be like a
loophole in the fact that they're a
non-profit like we need to find that
loophole
and expose them i think they tried to do
that and then they just threw so many
yeah
they are so litigious they are so
[ __ ] literally sued the irs yeah
the irs said we give like okay you guys
are tax-free
that's cool
it is crazy it's so it's so tricky
because it's like freedom of religion
that's constitutional if you like
prevent the scientist i mean the
scientologists commit an ungodly number
of crimes and those should be like
persecuted and prosecuted but it's like
we need to get their lawyers de-barred
but you know but they also will like
follow you around yeah if you break
through the church oh you don't oh it's
leah remini and uh
you know i know angelo he's been in here
and leah i met a couple times great and
then i saw her show one time and i
thought
how courageous somebody is
for whatever to take on general motors
or take on whatever but to be
a person and to say
that this is not right that when
somebody leaves you follow somebody and
you get like this close and you can't
touch them and you know you can't touch
them but everywhere you go
they're following you and they're
looking at you and they're and i mean
that
you know in religion you wouldn't expect
you wouldn't expect it it is
really courageous because like when a
whistleblower comes out and tells their
story and is able to verify it and that
is that is a grueling process like to be
able to come up with the evidence to
talk about your trauma in public and not
get sued like that paves the way for
other people to come out and speak
against the atrocities that they
experience because it's like okay this
person said it out loud and didn't get
sued so now i can say it out loud and
not get sued in we did a show in
clearwater and clearwater is like their
their central place and i looked outside
and and at the hotel and you you're like
okay there's a downtown right there
there's really nobody there then you see
the ass
and then we get in the car and we're
like is this a oh this is a whole big
thing and uh
nobody who lived in clearwater
as the scientology set up their
headquarters there would feel
comfortable coming downtown so it became
almost like a
wild west movie set where only those
people came downtown the people that
were from clearwater decided that since
i'm not one of them
i didn't feel comfortable going
downtown anymore and you could see it in
it you could see it from the window
you're like
and the
and the the building that was across
from me was a huge building and lights
on and no one in the building like
nobody in there at all ever
i mean you said this on one of our
episodes when we were touching on
scientology for a second like elrond
hubbard really just was kind of this
like super nerdy sci-fi buff who took it
way too far he could have been like jrr
tolkien and just like wrote a bunch of
lord of the rings type books not that
sophisticated but like and went on his
merry way and you were like what happens
when like a creative writer drops out
you know
and doesn't write anymore they're like
oh now i have to control people he was
getting a penny a page or some [ __ ] and
then and then uh
when he was in the navy he bombed his
own he bombed his own people like they
said you're out man yeah
he bombed this they bombed this
friendly fire
thank you so much for having us
check out the podcast sounds like a cult
uh check out amanda's books we have
cultish there's another book the word
it's called word [ __ ]
this one's called cultish the language
of fanaticism
language culture scientifically thank
you